we
confirm those facts revealed during
the special military operation
in Ukraine that testify
to the emergency cleansing by the Kiev regime of
traces of military biological programs;
they were implemented by Kiev with
funding from the United States of
America about any peaceful use of
scientific purposes for the benefit of the development world,
of course
that they were financed through the
United States Department of Defense,
we proceed from the fact that in the
near future the United States Department of Defense, the
administration of the
President of the United States are obliged to acquaint the
international community and do it
officially, they, through and talking heads,
with those programs that were
carried out in
Ukraine, the
set goals for the return of Ukraine
to the origins of and and sovereignty enshrined
in the declaration of independence, which
proclaimed its neutral status and
cooperation with Russia, as the
Russian leadership stated, would be
fulfilled and of course it would be better  so that this was
done through peaceful negotiations the
goals of a special military operation to protect the
inhabitants of the DPR and LPR
demilitarization and denazification of Ukraine
elimination of the war the threats of Russia that
leave the Ukrainian territory from its
development by NATO countries in an
appropriate way and the pumping of
weapons, its tasks do not include either the occupation of
Ukraine or the destruction of statehood
not overthrowing the current government, it is not
directed against the civilian population in
Russia, the alliance has never been threatened and do not
threaten now,
while Russia cannot but respond
to a confrontational course
towards our country